>>
Sir, could you start by introducing your company
and the (inaudible) your application?
>> Sure, so I’m with the Nextstop.com which
is a new community site for exchanging, interesting
things to do anywhere in the world. I’ve
really grew up of some frustrations that we
have when traveling about how hard it was
to find authentic things that gave you a rest
sense of a place that got beyond sort of the
top ten things to do in every place you go.
And really realized that if people who live
there are locals who knew the place well could
share recommendations for the things that
really got them excited about the place. You
haven’t got on much different experience
when you’re in a place you don’t know
that well.
>> So, how did you (inaudible) to decide to
use (inaudible) products?
>> Because one of the things we really focused
on a lot on their early days was the process
of adding a recommendation to the system.
We want them to make it really, really simple
for people to share the places that they loved
most. And to do that, we looked at a number
of different tools the sort of integrate existing
information about those places on the Web.
Local type results name and address, photos,
websites. And with those bunch of different
approaches for how we could sort of help put
that information together, but really found
that AJAX APIs had pretty fantastic global
coverage of almost anything that we found
people recommending between the sort of official
local search results and they came all results
almost anything that people recommended. We
could get a point on a map for. We could do
an image search tab bring in some related
images. We actually use the translation APIs
to do language deception on what people rate,
so we can properly categorize it and (inaudible)
it. And it really also became together in
the way that makes a process in making a recommendation
super, super easy.
>> So, from the note process, any worst stories?
>> Yeah, I mean, we’ve gone through all
sort of different ways of doing these. And
one of the things that – we thought was
really important from our early day was to
connect the recommendations people are making
with each other. So that, as a browser of
the site, I could go see – would you recommend,
but also the other things that people upset
about that place. And given the breath of
content that we have on the system, everything
from, you know, restaurants to hikes to biking
trails, figuring out how to merge that information
together is always a bit a challenging. You
know, if you have a phone number for everything,
it’s pretty easy, but when you’re trying
to sort of determine whether these two things
are close enough in space to be the same thing
or to be different things, there are a lot
of sort of (inaudible) situations. But, we’ve
learned through the, you know, (inaudible)
coding API and the local search results’
ways of sort of trying to make those make
those decisions.
>> Sir, when we’re trying to (inaudible),
but functionality be AJAX APIs really helped
to bring back (inaudible)?
>> Well, I think, you know, a lot of it was
just making the data about these places accessible
and the way that we could manipulate and process
it, so that we could kind of decide whether
these two things were the same or different.
The fact that you got a lot of information
back from the local search API, you know,
with the phone number, with the address, search
the, you know, applies a lot of the data necessarily
into that.
>> So, it’s really which APIs that you use
again?
>> So, we’re using the AJAX Local Search
API, the Image Search API. We’re using the
Translation API. But actually, using the,
I guess that’s called the GU Location API
part of the downloader.
>> So, what are some of the features you’re
finally implement, (inaudible) gives you to
the future?
>> Well, we think of one of the things that
we could a lot more with is a Translation
API. You know, we’re global community of
people sharing recommendations all over the
place. And right now, most of that is an English,
but we think with some well applied machine
translation. We can actually make that content
accessible to a much greater variety of people.
So that’s something we’re really excited
about as we’re experimenting more.
>> That’s great. So, how (inaudible) I open,
have you really – what do you going to take
way from the conference do you think?
>> It’s been a lot of fun. I’ve met a
lot of interesting people who’ve come buy
our developed pad and you know (inaudible)
of this morning for Google Wave was great,
one of the best times as I’ve seen in a
long time.
>> Cool. I thank you so much and being part
of this.
>> Thanks a lot.